[Musique]
Vernon
Normandie sur cette photo d'école prise
dans les années 50 une tenue des notes
par rapport à celle des autres un petit
garçon blond porte une culotte courte en
cuir la tenue traditionnelle
bavaroise une colonie allemande av ici
au milieu des bois juste après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale que venait-il
faire en France alors que le pays se
remet difficilement des 4 années
d'occupation nazi quel mystère entourait
ces familles elles ne sont pas les
seules dans
l'Hexagone dans le plus grand secret des
milliers d'Allemands ont été transférés
sur le sol français j'ai penser que
cette cette organisation de prendre les
gens pour les déplacé dans dans un autre
pays pour travailler c'est en quelque
sorte une prise de guerre à von on a
loger
les scientifiques les inurs
techniciens qui devaient être
interrogé avant d'arriver en France ces
hommes ont fait l'objet d'une traque
impitoyable leurs poursuivants sont des
scientifiques versés dans
l'armée parmi
eux car un célèbre physicien
français mon grand-père était un peu les
derniers toucheat tout de la physique on
pouvait pas le rouler dans la farine
quoi l'Allemagne a été passée au
peignefin pour retrouver des
scientifiques qui ont servi le 3è
Raich à quel degré ces brillants
cerveaux étaient-il impliqués dans le
régime nazi ils ont pris tout le monde
même ceux qui étaient dans dans SS c'est
une ombre de l'histoire
terrible je pense qu'il y a une
responsabilité morale c'est
sûr ces scientifiques vont eux-mêmes
retracer leur parcours de l'Allemagne
hitlérienne à la France de
l'après-guerre leur voix se mêlent à
celle des scientifiques français qui les
ont recherchés pour une plongée
intimiste et inédite dans l'une des plus
vastes opérations de pillage de la
science nazie du 20e
siècle
[Musique]
plusieurs milliers de scientifiques
allemands ont commencé leur carrière ici
à pinemund tout au nord de l'Allemagne
dans un gigantesque centre de recherche
qui ne figure sur aucune carte depuis
1942 l'Allemagne nazie conduit là son
programme d'armes
nouvelles personne ne
connaissait à part les les militaires et
les gens au pouvoir autrement c'était
c'était archi
secret les parents d'Herbert Bull
avaient été recrutés par l'armée
allemande comme des milliers d'autres
ingénieurs
[Musique]
ma mère était
dessinatrice très bonne dessinatrice mon
père est donc était
ingénieur spécialisé dans le guidage des
fusées Herbert Bull vit aujourd'hui en
Allemagne il a grandi en France c'est
lui le petit garçon de la photo d'école
prise en Normandie dans les années
50 son histoire familiale se mêle avec
celle des débuts de la recherche
aérospatiale mon père et ma mère ont
travaillaé dans l'équipe de fon Brown
donc il faut dire que c'était un grand
centre de
recherche dans le domaine de la fusée
des V1 et des
V2 Werner von Brown dirige une équipe de
chercheurs qui espère être les premiers
à réussir à envoyer un objet dans
l'espace leurs travaux ont attiré
l'attention au gradé de la
s il y avait par exemple Himla un
dirigeant au niveau militaire qui avait
visité pénemund et qui avait vu
l'intérêt desv1 et des
V2 mais pour attaquer d'autres
[Musique]
pays nous hum l'impression arrivant de
nous trouver dans un monde peint par Jul
Verne l'ensemble était extrêmement
impressionnant la hauteur des fusées
exigeant des ateliers de montage adapté
en
conséquence pierre de Conde est un jeune
employé français envoyé en Allemagne il
appartient à un bataillon de
travailleurs
forcés nous apprimes par nos camarades à
quoi était destiné la production du AAT
artillerie parc 22 il s'agissait de
mettre au point une fusée la de qui
d'après les rumeurs qui circulaient
devait effectuer une destruction totale
dans un rayon de 20 km lors de son
impact il y a bien longtemps ça fait 61
ans que j'ai commencé l'histoire des
fusées en 41 il y avait un essai nous
sommes allés euh
à la plage pour voir de loin le départ
de la fusée c'était formidable elle
montait et tout à coup on a entendu un
son là
il la fusée est revenue et tombé dans
l'eau al il y avait une série des des
essais qui ne marchaient
pas
et enfin le 2 octobre 42 c'est la
première fois qu'il y avait un essai qui
était
réussi après il y avait un dîner au MES
hôtel des officiers tout le monde était
heureux
les Alliés apprennent l'existence de ces
nouvelles menaces on parle pour la V1 de
bombe robot ces armes meurtrières sont
pointées sur
[Musique]
Londres Francis Rocard
astrophysicien a conservé sur des bandes
enregistrées les souvenirs de son
grand-père Yve Rocard il était le père
de Michel Rocard l'ancien Premier
ministre et surtout un grand physicien
français
en juin 1944 il est conseiller
scientifique du général de Gaulle qui a
rejoint à
Londres à cette époque j'avais la tête
farcie des installations fort bizarres
des allemand sur les côtes de Normandie
la crainte diffuse d'une arme inconnue
nos
esprits en septembre
1944 les prires fusée V2 s'abatt sur
Londres j'ouvre la porte du couloir plus
de couloir je m'approche d'une fenêtre
sur la cour plus de cour elle était
remplie de décombres du toit le ciel
nocturne hérissé de faisceaux de
projecteur rougeoyait avec des incendies
de tous côtés en franchissant sans la
fenêtre pour descendre sur mon toit j'
eu pendant quelques instants la vision
dentesque de Londres en flamme sous
l'effet d'armes secrètes
d'Hitler mon grand-père évidemment était
au courant de l'existence des V1 et des
V2 mon grand-père par ses compétences
techniques a a eu vent de plusieurs
avancées technologiques
allemandes all Londres on a besoin
d'hommees capable de décrypter ses
nouvelles armes c'est la première fois
qu'un engin volant explose à 300 km de
son point de
[Musique]
décollage à Toulon en France vit l'un
des derniers témoins de ces avancées
spectaculaires
Ursula Mendel à 101 ans elle est née en
Allemagne et son destin est étroitement
lié au trè Reich
son père était l'un des généraux
d'Hitler je voulais absolument
travailler pour parce qu'on était déjà
en guerre et je voulais pas faire un
métier sans sans
aider à notre victoire
Ursula est alors une toute jeune femme
qui a fait partie des jeunesses
hitlriennes
elle a 20 ans quand la guerre
éclate je me suis complètement fait
prendre par cette éternelle réclame que
tout le monde les journaux et tout on
fait autour de Hitler Hitler magnifique
il fait ceci il fait cela oh quel
magnifique oh mais moi je le cru moi
j'étais une une fanatique pour
Hitler si j'avais su tout ce qui se
passait en notre nom et qu'il avait
toutes ces atrocités autour de nous bah
j'aurais été probaement Franch rencontre
mais en ne sachant rien de tout ça c'est
c'est devenu une
normalité les industries civiles sont
convertis pour fabriquer des armes toute
la population allemande est
réquisitionné
Ursula passe la guerre à travailler dans
les usines elle devient l'assistante
d'un ingénieur en charge de la
conception de l'aile d'une torpille
larguée d'un avion
[Musique]
c'était une aile une aile qu'on aurait
pu mettre sur n'importe quoi mais elle
était prédestinée à être mis sur une
tampille à l'époque ça n'existait pas
c'est probablement un dernier espoir de
gagner cette c'éit
guerre c'était assez redoutable le
principe c'est que le pilote avait une
bombe avec des ailes et et la bombe est
larguée et le pilote avait deux manches
à Balet il pilotait son avion et il
pilotait la bombe et donc il faisait en
sorte que la bombe pointe vers le bateau
et et le bateau
explosait les Alliés demandent à
ivrocard de trouver une
parade j'ai fait des petits brouilleurs
que j'ai fait installer sur tous nos
croiseurs un a servi au moment du
débarquement dans le midi les bombes ont
été s'écraser à 500 m derrière autrement
dit j'ai eu des petits succès
techniques les armées de l'air anglais
et américaines reprennent peu à peu le
contrôle de l'espace
[Musique]
aérien maintenant la guerre se rapproche
de plus en plus de notre sol bien-aimé
doning a souffert de la première attaque
aérienne de la bribar avec les belles
maisons à colombage est détruite il y a
beaucoup de morts c'est horrible tout
les villages entre danahingen et le lac
de Constance ont subi des raides
aériens nous allons nous y
habituer comme toutes les autres régions
avant
nous nous nous trouvons dans une
situation très difficile j'espère que
nous pourrons nous en sortir une fois de
plus jusqu'ici nous réussissons au prix
d'infinis soucis et peu de
sommeil je recevais quand même assez
lettre de sa part pour voir que qu'il
était très
pessimiste mon père il croyait plus du
tout mais il a fait son devoir de solda
jusqu'à la fin parce que c'était ça
c'était pas parce qu'il était nazi
c'était parce que il était
soldat les armes miracles n'ont pas
permis de changer le cours de la guerre
le territoire des vaincus est réduit à
un champ de ruine mais pour les Alliés
c'est aussi une mine d'or de technologie
d'avant-garde qui suscite déjà la
convoitise des
[Musique]
vainqueurs par un beau matin de 19 45
j'étais assis dans la cabine d'un camion
de l'aviation américaine en train de
rebondir sur les routes semées de trous
de bombe dans le centre de l'Allemagne
j'étais en mission mais c'était une
curieuse mission j'avais dans la poche
des ordres secrets m'assignant à
l'exécution du projet lusti une
opération extra rapide menée par
l'aviation américaine pour débusquer et
mettre la main sur tous les savants
nazis
d'Allemagne l'opération lusti n'était
qu'une partie du plan général nommé
opération
papercilip papercilip est le nom du plan
secret Américains les Anglais et les
Soviétiques ont prévu d'en faire
autant mais les savants d'Hitler ont
reçu l'ordre de dissimuler leurs
travaux les forêts les tunnels les
grottes leur ont servi de cachette pour
échapper aux alliés des milliers d'entre
eux se sont fondus dans le flot des
réfugiés parmi eux Werner von Brown le
concepteur des fusés nazi il s'est
volatilisé avec tous ses
spécialistes c'était la
décision
du du service militaire à Berlin qu'il
fallait évacuer penemun
aussi bien les scientifiques que que
tout le savoir les les papiers les les
documents et de se retirer dans la
forteresse bavaroise parce que ça
c'était l'idée de Hitler qu'on allait
retrouver un refuge dans les
Alpes cétait complètement idiot mais
c'était c'était leur
idée il n'y a plus de sanctuaire le
réduit bavarois dont Hitler avait fait
sa retraite tombe à son tour
en mai
1945 toute l'Allemagne prise en tenaille
entre les armées américaines anglaises
française et soviétique de l'autre est
occupé les concepteurs des fusées se
rendent leur chef Werner von Brown est
soulagé le jour de son arrestation il
est sorti vivant du
chaos
mon père d'abord se trouvait en sécurité
avec avec toute l'équipe avec F Brown
pour eux c'était vraiment primordial et
crucial de tomber sous la
main des Américains parce que là on
était sûr qu'ils étaient bien traités et
que de toute façon il ils étaient
reconnus pour leur Scien et pour leur
[Musique]
savoir dans les capitales européennes
alors que les populations se réjouissent
de la chute du 3è Reich l'inquiétude
monte parmi leurs gouvernants à Paris le
gouvernement provisoire a appris que les
Américains avaient retrouvé les
spécialistes des fusées le temps presse
pour profiter de cette manne
exceptionnelle il faut reconstruire le
pays ruiné par 5 années
d'occupation moi-même je revenais de la
guerre j'étais habillé en marin
ingénieur en chef de la marine j'avais
eu des négociations avec le chef du
deuxè bureau de la marine il m'a appuyé
sur l'idée qu'il fallait faire un effort
considérable pour mettre la main sur les
techniques allemandes les technicien
allemand après la guerre parce queil y
avait tellement de choses pour
lesquelles nous recevions des coups sans
comprendre j'avais le sentiment que nous
avions beaucoup à
apprendre il y a un obstacle majeur la
France à genou après 5 années
d'occupation a collaboré avec l'ennemi
elle est donc tenue à l'écart du butin
des vainqueurs
le général de Gaulle qui dirige le
gouvernement provisoire va s'interposer
au nom de l'intérêt supérieur de la
France de Gaul pense que le pays ne peut
pas se passer de l'pport
allemand secrètement il donne l'ordre à
son armée de faire main basse sur les
savants
[Musique]
d'Hitler il y aura lieu de transférer en
France les scientifiques ou techniciens
de grande valeur pour les faire
interroger à loisir sur leurs travaux et
éventuellement les engager à rester à
notre
[Musique]
disposition alors la Marine a monté une
petite section qui s'appelait la section
th marine comportant peut-être une
centaine d'hommes sous les ordres d'un
lieutenant de vaisseau avec un armement
léger pour accompagner les armées
français au fur et à mesure qu'elles
envillissaient l'Allemagne et c'était
moi qui inspira leur et le
travail il a été envoyé en
Allemagne alors que la France n'y avait
pas droit c'était juste les gagnants
c'est-à-dire les Américains et les
Anglais mais discrètement les Français
le faisaient
également des unités de recherche vont
donc se mêler aux troupes du général de
lâtre de tassigne terre mer air chaque
corps d'armée possède sa propre section
scientifique par pragmatisme le haut
commandement français s'apprête à
désobéir au consiges des Alliés et la
chance va lui
sourire de nombreux laboratoires
importants ont été évacué dans l'état du
Wurtenberg on attendait impatiemment que
cette zone soit occupée quand de
nouvelles complications ont surgi ce
territoire scientifiquement désirable
allait être pris par les troupes
françaises
le général de Gaulle a joué là encore un
rôle déterminant à force d'insister
auprès de winon Churchill il arrache en
juillet
1945 la promesse que la France aura elle
aussi le droit d'occuper une partie de
l'Allemagne le pays a finalement été
divisé en quatre zones attribué à
chacune des armées qui l'ont envahi le
petit territoire attribué à la France
est prometteur il comprend le lac de
Constance au bord duquel des centaines
ingénieurs allemands ont trouvé
refuge tous sont poursuivi leur travail
jusqu'au
bout parmi eux il y a Ursula Mendel
toujours occupée à des calculs pour
améliorer l'aile de la torpille
planante c'était des officiers qui
venaient en tant que force occupante
c'est ça nous gênait pas du tout ils
étaient très correct ils nous regardent
faire cétait très intéressé par
notreelle c'était un peu nos patrons en
quelque
sorte ma position personnelle était de
parler très poliment aux Allemands que
je voyais là et de dire ce que vous avez
fait est très intéressant continuez s'il
vous plaît on vous met simplement de
Marant en faction devant la porte pour
que vous puissiez continuer de
travailler
tranquille Yv Rocard note toutes ses
recherches dans des carnets à de
nombreuses reprises il se déplace en
Allemagne pour interroger les
scientifiques leur nom leur fonction
leurs travaux tout est recensé ici de
manière méticuleuse
ivrocar reconstitue intégralement les
organismes des instituts technologiques
allemands alors le spectre est assez
large donc on peut citer donc ces
affaires de torpill électron magnétique
sur lequel il s'est intéressé on peut
citer donc les bombes volantes mais
aussi tout ce qui était cellulle au
sulfure de plomb cellules infraroug et
et donc il y avait une avancée dans ce
domaine en Allemagne et ça a été
récupéré à ce
moment-là l'Allemagne se révèle être un
eldorado pour tous les scientifiques
dépêchés sur
place on découvre ici le nouveau
carburant propergol liquide des fusées
nazis là ce sont les éléments d'une
installation révolutionnaire pour
l'époque qu'on achemine en
France c'est une soufflerie un
équipement destiné à tester
l'aérodynamie des avions et des fusées
elle est remonté pièce par pièce à
Modane en
Savoie
le site est toujours utilisé c'est
encore la plus grande soufflerie du
[Musique]
monde pour exploiter ces avancées
technologiques il faut pouvoir mettre la
main sur leurs brillants
inventeurs parmi les hommes les plus
convoités il y a les patrons du complexe
militaroindustriel Ferdinand Porsche est
activement recherché chef de
l'entreprise de moteur Porsche il a mis
son empire au service
d'Hitler il a fabriqué ses avions ses
chars et du matériel de guerre en
quantité
industrielle mais il demeure introuvable
comme Willy m Schmith le grand
fournisseur d'avion de la Luft Waffle
armée de l'air allemande est l'inventeur
du premier avion à réaction du monde
[Musique]
j'ai monté une sorte de commando j'ai
capturé m Schmid qui était sur le point
d'être évacué par une unité s vers la
Suisse et j'ai pu le ramener vers les
lignes
allié j'avais déjà récupéré toutes les
archives de Monsieur schmidth au fond
d'un lac où ils avaient été immergés
dans le Tyrol et le dernier camion
français partait lorsqu est arrivé tout
un bataillon
américain avec des forces puissantes qui
sont arrivé un peu après la bataille
d'as il m' ont
voulu les Américains ont
reprism français ont eu le temps de
l'interroger et de copier ses
travaux les Alliés se livrent une
concurrence
féroce des scientifiques disparaissent
mystérieusement j'avais mis la main sur
d'excellents ingénieurs et agent
technique d'un laboratoire de torpille
ces ALM est regroupé dans une grosse
ferme des environs de
cresborne nos premiers ennuis vent de
nos concurrents américains qui avaient
mis le cap sur le même groupe que nous
le conseiller de l'armée américaine le
célèbre von Carmon me dit vous les
Français vous êtes bien naïf de croire
que ces Allemands sont tous des génies
il ne m'encourageit pas du tout à
traiter avec les technicien allemands
mais il déclencha l'action des services
secrets américains dans le but de faire
évader des Allemands ceuxci quittait la
zone française enlever un eutre barbe
dans une voiture
américaine
[Musique]
il y a eu de nombreuses équipes qui ont
fait ça les américainsont fait
énormément les Anglais aussi c'était un
peu chacun se c'était un peu des pots de
banane et compagnie on se faisait pas de
cadeau
voilà pour les convaincre de rester au
service de la France les scientifiques
allemands sont
choyés un petit groupe de spécialistes
de fusé est dans cette
aubergeing pendant qu'il dessine les
plans des V2 les autorités françaises
prennent en charge tous les aspects
[Musique]
matériels nous étions une trentaine
d'ingénieurs nég avec ministère des
armé l' a bien
évolué des documents
français
familles nous avion un supplément de
nourriture ce qui à
l'époqueimportant la misère
quiem
vilelm dolopf vérifiait les calculs des
moteurs de fusée V2 il était soulagé
d'avoir retrouver du
travail ce qu'on sait très rarement
c'est que en Allemagne les restrictions
ont commencé le premier jour de la
guerre en 39 si bien que à la fin de la
guerre nous avions vraiment faim on
était vraiment sous
[Musique]
alimentés
des dizaines de laboratoires allemands
travaillent ainsi pendant plus d'un an
pour le compte de l'armée et de la
recherche
[Musique]
française nous sommes en mars 46 en
plein travail sur notre empenage pour
torpille planante quand surgit
l'ingénieur du génie maritime il déclare
que notre travail doit cesser en
Allemagne la consternation est grande
les recherches à but militaire sont
interdites sur le sol allemand pour
éviter que l'Allemagne ne se réarme et
ne redevienne une puissance
[Musique]
hostile au bout de quelques mois il y eu
les instructions de déménager en France
les institutions que nous av on
fondé si on veut continuer à exploiter
ce potentiel ces ingénieurs ces gens qui
connaissent et bien il faut les faire
venir en France donc il y a pas trop de
de il y a pas trop de d'alternative et
évidemment pour pour nous c'était très
étonnant parce que on pensait que après
la guerre des des des des déplacement
forcés comme ça c'est n'était plus
possible et c'est là où on fait des
propositions à l'échante euh un peu
carotter le bâton hein je me souviens
que mon grand-père me disait que il
arrivait avec des propositions de faire
venir la famille de salaire et cetera
euh mais aussi s'il refusait ben en gros
il les emmenait de
[Musique]
force pour les savants d'Hitler c'est
l'exode les ÉtatsUnis ont déjà transféré
sur leur territoire 118 spécialistes des
fusées avec leur in en chef wner von
Brown qui deviendra l'architecte du
programme spatial
[Musique]
américain les Soviétiques vont organiser
le déménagement forcé de milliers de
chercheurs en
[Musique]
URSS des voix s'élèvent pour protester
contre l'arrivée d'ancien
nazis mais qui était-il vraiment ces
collaborateurs aés du 3è
Reich
[Musique]
j'ai encore les laissés passer pour
entrer en France pour aller à Paris et à
Paris on était reçu à la gare de l'Est
du deuxè bureau ils était là avec de
voitures je crois et on nous a amené vos
dans le château de
vosç c'est làun je crois Monsieur
L don je n'ai plus jamais entendu parler
par la
suite
interroger il nous a posé des questions
sur nos activités pendant la
guerre sur ce que nous
savions mon père a été
questionné on lui a remis un
questionnaire à remplir et là il a écrit
dedans qu'il avait été
sa donc la France et aussi les
américains ils savaient qu' qu'il était
sa ils sont quand même intéressés
[Musique]
la SA est la première milice privée qui
dans les années 30 a œuvré pour ouvrir
la voix du pouvoir aux fascistes en
Allemagne si on
voulait faire quelque chose il fallait
être dans
laasa ça prouvit qu'on est qu'on était
engagé pour
euh pour pour le régime quoi à mon avis
il faut différencier entre un engagement
fort et un
engagement un peu
banal il est rentré dans la SA pas la SS
hein la SA hein et il en est
ressorti quelques années plus tard
hein pour
moi je pense que mon
père n'était pas tellement engagé
là-dedans hein
on
devait sur
Hitler jurer fidélité et tout ça au Fura
et après c'était practiquement pas
possible de s'en aller sans
[Musique]
difficulté Carles benke travaillait lui
aussi sur les V2 il a subi le même
interrogatoire de la part des services
secrets
français mon père à pénmunde il était
scientifique mais je ne pense pas qu'il
est qu'il est vraiment adhérer aux idées
d'Hitler je on peut pas dire qu'on en
ait discuté vraiment ensemble mais mais
c'est le sentiment que j'ai et c'était
quelqu'un de bon je pense qu' faisait
son travail
voilà Carl benke a adhéré à laasa à
partir de
1934 et plus tard au parti nazi Christel
sa fille n'était pas au
courant la tentation de tirer un trait
sur la guerre de cacher son engagement
politique a été très répandu dans
l'Allemagne de l'après-guerre c'est ce
que découvr la Mendel le jour où à son
tour on vient
l'interroger la sécurité navale est
venue chez moi juste avant monter par
c'était un officier de la sécurité qui
était comme tâche de voir les Allemands
dangereux ou pas et cetera et
ça alors il m'a demandé vous étiez pas
naz ah j'ai dit Monsieur c'est c'est
c'est assez difficile quelqu'un trouvver
en Allemagne et il n'était pas nacis en
quelque sorte oui j'étais NAC et puis
alors
finalement il était un peu pris à cours
il s'est levé il s'est un peu incliné
devant moi il m'a dit mademoiselle vous
êtes le premier nacis que je rencontre
en Allemagne de mon côté vous avez rien
à
craindre ça c'était et ça ça m'a mise
dans une couleur noire contre les
Allemands mais je dis mais comment il se
comp te que un officier me dise ça qui
me dise mademoiselle vous êtes le
premier nazis que je rencontre en
Allemagne mais ça
c'est c'est inadmissible pour moi parce
que ça vous montrer que on s'est mis
derrière un
parabluie on était pour rien alors qu'on
était qu'on était ce qu'on était on ne
pouvait très bien avouer ce qu'on
[Musique]
était aucun profil n'arrête les
recruteurs
même les plus compromis
autoambros chimiste ami personnel dimler
a donné son feu vert à l'usage du ziclom
B à
Auschwitz c'est le gaz utilisé pour
l'extermination des Juifs d'Europe
autoambros est sur la liste des
criminels de
guerre pourtant à la Libération il est
embauché par une entreprise française de
colorants
chimique
la France finit par le livrer aux
Américains ce tribunal dressé pour juger
les crimes commis à
Auschwitz le condamne à 8 ans de prison
en
1947 combien d'autres ont échappé à tout
[Musique]
jugement pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale au centre de l' Allemagne près
de nordzen une gigantesque usine
souterraine a été creusée sur ordre des
nazis en
1943 il fallait poursuivre la
fabrication des V2 dans un lieu sûr à
l'abri des bombardements
alliés quand les troupes américaine
découvrent le site en avril 1945
elle découvre
l'enfer la construction du camp de Dora
a été une
écatombe les soldats américains évacuent
les corps suppliciés des déporté forcé à
travailler jusqu'au dernier jour dans
les entrailles militaires du
[Musique]
régime nous sommes restés 72 heur debout
sans nourriture et sans sommeil des
grappes humaines de cornus s'agglutiner
les unes aux autres afin de rechercher
un semblant de
chaleur
comment résister à une température de
moins 25 degrés vision dentesque
ahurissante il mourrait bien d'avantage
d'hommes qu'il ne sortait de
fusée ces dessins ont été réalisés sur
place par un prisonnier français ils
témoignent de la brutalité des
capots les ingénieurs étaient présents
comme le prouve ces clichés pris par un
photographe officiel du
régime comment se sont-ils comportés
envers cette main- d'œuvre réduite en
[Musique]
esclavage au début du mois de mars 1944
on nous a annoncé la visite d'un groupe
d'ingénieurs l'un d'eux m'a pererçu et a
foncé vers moi m'a giflé invectivé m'a
accusé de sabotage parce que j'avais
posé le pied sur un petit moteur de
guidage de l'aileron de la
fusée après son départ mon chef d'équipe
m'a dit qu'il s'agissait de wner von
Brown paraît qu'il y avait du sabotage
aussi dans ces galeries souterraines que
les Allemands bien sûr essayaient de
détecter à temps mais certainement que
que ça eu lieu et celui qui était pris
évidemment c'est très très malheureux
c'était la peine de mort tout ça c'est
c'est sûr que c'est c'est une ombre de
l'histoire
terrible des dizaines d'autres sites
souterrains ont été construits pour la
fabrication des armes du régime nazi
laissant dans leur sillage des milliers
de
morts
oh là là il est
fragile contrat de prestation de service
entre le ministère de l'armement et
Mademoiselle M
soua ourursoua Mendel décroche à son
tour en 1947 un contrat d'assistante
technique dans un laboratoire de la
marine
française c'était tellement incroyable
que ça s'est passé comme
ça que et personne a vu ce filtre qu'ils
auraiit pu mettre en dire
elle est la fille de général qui s'est
passé en Normandie contre nous qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on en fasse
non non non ça ça
passé leur degré d'adhésion au régime
nazi a été très variable seule certitude
la France a accueilli plusieurs milliers
d'anciens collaborateurs du 3e Reich on
estime leur nombre à 5000
[Musique]
environ Vernon s'offre à la flanerie des
roches quelques grottes allons voir un
carrefour une plaque
LRBA il faut montrer pâes blanche pour
entrer au laboratoire de recherche
balistique et aérodynamique de
Vernon c'était caché sur le plateau
complètement à l'extérieur de Vernon et
et pratiquement les autres Français de
Vernon n'avaient ni accès ni grosse
connaissance de de ces lieux
en mai
1946 un premier groupe s'installe 70
ingénieurs qui ont mis au point les V2
sont chargés de doter la France d'une
fusée peu à peu on construit pour eux
une soufflerie des stands d'essais pour
les
moteurs une cité de l'espace vois le
jour
au mois de septembre 47 je suis arrivé à
vernong moi j'étais dans la section
vanne sous
pape j'avais une chambre au baracem eux
à l'entrée qui sont détruits maintenant
on était bien traité on était content
travailler en
[Musique]
France sur ces images rares tournées par
l'un de ces scientifiques on aperçoit
les maisons mises à leur
disposition les femmes et les enfants
rejoignent les pirres de famille dans
les mois qui
suivent le déménagement est pris en
charge les salaires sont bon la France
leur a déroulé le tapis
[Musique]
rouge pour vivre pour jouer tout ça on
était très bien très bien au l'erba
d'ailleurs on disait toujours lieu de
repos bien
aménagé c'est vrai que pour les enfants
c'était c'était le paradis hein de jouer
moi je faisais des gros bouquets de
muguet chercher des mur avec mes avec ma
mère des fraises des bois parce que il
mettait ça dans du vin blanc et c'était
la ble c'est un une boisson qu'on buvait
en Allemagne c'est un genre de sangria
quoi les PR premières années la colonie
allemande reproduit son mode de vie à
l'identique les fêtes traditionnelles
comme le carnaval des enfants ponctuent
l'année à première vue l'arrivée des
spécialistes en Normandie ne pose aucune
difficulté je crois que la
peur d'aller à l'étranger a été tout de
suite oublié voyant comment on les
traitait en France ils étaient traités
aussi bien au point de
vue
paiement comme un Français ils étaient
très bien
payés un second groupe rejoint le
premier pour construire des moteurs de
char la colonie allemande compte
désormais 130
scientifiques de nouvelles maisons sont
mises en chantier alors que la ville de
Vernon bombardée par l'aviation
allemande en 1940 n'est toujours pas
reconstruite la ville elle a été quand
même beaucoup détruite dévastée et les
vernonnais de voir ces camions qui
montaient avec des des des aglos du
ciment enfin du sable tout ce qu'il
fallait pour construire bah il le
prenait pas très bien ce qui est tout à
fait logique et c'est franchement après
toute cette violence qui a été
connu de par la faute des Allemands moi
je je comprends
[Musique]
cette installation aux portes d'une cité
meurtrie déclenche l'hostilité des
[Musique]
habitants les enfants allemands
scolarisé avec les Français le
ressentent on était reconnu de loin avec
cette culotte en cuir il y avait une
haine les Français traitient les
Allemands de Bos
les les écoliers les camarades scolaires
reprenaient ça on s'est quand même
interrogé sur toutout sur tout ce qu'on
a toute l'histoire finalement des
Allemands à
Vernon toute façon on était très jeune
mais on se disait bah tiens pourquoi on
est mal vu pourquoi on a des problèmes
pourquoi il y a des tensions notre frère
aîné lui lui il il avait je dirais à peu
près 18 ans et lui il est allé
travailler comme apprenti
chez un
électricien en ville et donc il allait
faire des installations chez des
[Musique]
particuliers Carl benke a placé son fils
en apprentissage chez un électricien
français et là lui il a subi un quelques
agressions c'était plus difficile battu
sauvagement le jeune homme en gardera
des séquelles sa famille n'a jamais
porté
plainte ben ça a été assumé on a fait du
mieux qu'on a pu mais voilà hm hm
ouais ouais
mais enfin c'est c'est faut avouer que
c'est une période qui n'était pas
facile l'arrivée des Allemands suscite
partout la peur et
l'incompréhension à deis dans la Nièvre
170 ingénieurs débarquent en juillet
1946 avec leurs 272 wagons remplis
d'outillage ils ne pouvaient pas passer
inaperçu aujourd'hui nos rues sont à
nouveau pleines de silhouettes que nous
reconnaissons pour les avoir trop connu
l'uniforme n est plus mais nous
reconnaissons l'allure et le
regard les de decise se rappelle surtout
les derniers tetons ivres de fureur et
armé jusqu'aux dents partir en
expédition contre les maquis du
Morvent personne
n'oublie les crainte de la population
n'ont pas pesé lourd face à la raison
d'État l'ingénieur en chef du groupe
hermanustrich a mis au point l'un des
tout premiers moteurs à réaction ces
bombardiers Me262 représentaient une
avancée technologique majeure pour venir
travailler en France le ministère de
l'armement lui a fait un pont d'or
ustrich a dicté ses conditions pour
mettre au point le premier moteur à
réaction
français 5 % du prix lui revient sur
chaque exemplaire
fabriqué le gouvernement français
entouré d'une discrétion maximale
l'installation de dizaines de
laboratoires civils et militaires les
moteurs à réaction à Decis les
sous-marins à Cherbourg les avions de
chasse à Melin dans tous ces centres des
Allemands travaillent pour la France car
la priorité est donnée au retour du pays
parmi les puissances
[Musique]
mondiales à mon arrivée ici en février
les arbres et les buissons de mimosa
ployait sous leurs charg luxuriante à
Fréjus je fais la connaissance de mes
nouveaux camarades ce sont des
ingénieurs amené ici d'office mais ils
disent qu'ils s'y plaisent bien le
personnel allemand se compose d'une
trentaine d'ingénieurs et d'une dizaine
de techniciens je suis appelée chez le
professeur beatel physicien il
m'apprendra en acoustique sous-marine
tout ce qui me sera utile plus tard
pendant 4 ans nous travaillerons
ensemble au début nous étions des
ingénieurs et techn allemand avec je
crois on avait de techniciens français
tout tout ce qu' était scientifique ou
ça cétait dirigé par par les Allemands
Ursula Mendel fait partie des effectifs
embauchés par la marine elle travaille
dans l'un des trois centres
expérimentaux de la Côte d'Azur ouvert
grâce au recrutement
d'ivrocar j'avais embé ces ingénieurs et
techniciens qui étaient très bons et
qu'on a transféré en France au
laboratoire du brusque ils avaient la
solution pour ces orpill qui se retourne
sous les bateaux et explos
entre Français et Allemand ça marchait
très très bien et plus le travail que je
faisais était finalement important plus
j'étais contente que je pouvais montrer
que c'était possible parce que il est
presque incroyable que j'étais une des
rares personnes qui est était au courant
qu'il av qu'il va avoir des des
soumarins nucléire
c'était c'était c'était classifié la
marine française avait sacré confiance
en moi
Ursula Mendel passe son diplôme
d'ingénieur et sert fidèlement les
intérêts de la France les autorités
militaires lui impose un silence complet
sur la nature de son
travail dans son contrat il est écrit
qu'en cas d'espionnage c'est la peine de
mort j'ai trouvé ça un peu dur mais que
ce soit déjà dans un contrat mais j'ai
dit bon mais s'ils veulent s'ils veulent
qu'on le sache c'est le truc qui
d'ailleurs ça risquit pas beaucoup que
que qu'il fallait moins le dire parce
que je suis né dans une famille
militaire où on savait de quoi on peut
parler de quoi on peut pas parler ça je
savais déjà tout petit
quoi
Ursula Mendel a été une pionnière elle a
créé le premier service de mesure des
bruits sous-marins une discipline
nouvelle qui a permis d'augmenter la
sécurité à bord des
submersibles les sous-marigners c'était
les premiers qui ont compris que j'avais
raison et qui m'ont qui m'ont adopté à
partir de ce
momentlà maintenant il y a des oreill
d'or c'est c'est vraiment devenu quelque
chose qui
est que qui a a été
compris la greffe a pris les premiers
instituts de recherche franco-allemand
voient le jour leurs travaux vont
permettre à la France de rattraper son
retard
finalement Vail que vaille avec le temps
les Français les Allemands vont se
réconcilier c'est effectivement ce qui
s'est
passé à la fin des années 50 le fruit de
ces collaborations se concréti
[Musique]
le 22e salon de l'aéronautique qui vous
est présenté révèle au monde étonné le
prodigieux essur de notre aéronautique
nationale depuis la guerre nos
constructeurs nos centres d'ESS nos
services techniques ont fait d'une
industrie mise en sommeil pendant les
hostilités une des plus florissantes et
sement la plus vivante qui
soit sal
1957 est une vitrine mondiale pour les
réalisations technologiques
françaises le pays vient de se doter de
ses premiers avions à
[Musique]
réaction Marc France intercepteur et
avion d'appui transonique qui équipe les
forces aériennes de
lotane personne ne précise que le
concepteur du premier moteur à réaction
est allemand Herman l'a mis au point à
de
sise les prouesses technologiques
éblouissent les visiteurs mais leur ADN
reste
inconnu le jein est un hélicoptère léger
qui bat des records
d'altitude le nom des deux ingénieurs
allemands qui l'ont conçu n'est jamais
prononcé le clou du salon de l'espace
c'est cette paril futuriste
àarant C400 P2 France appareil
expérimental pour l'étude du décollage
et de l'atterrissage à la verticale
constr par la S on songe à équiper le
réacteur d'une aile annulaire don la
partie intérieur sera pourvu d'un stato
réacteur lete ELM vborovski en est
l'inventeur il faisait partie des unités
d'élite de l'ASS mais c'est aussi
enlevé à la fin de la guerre aux
Américains arrivé en France il a mis au
point le premier avion à décollage
vertical au
monde s'il ne s'était pas craché lors
d'un essai ce curieux engin aurait
propulsé la France dans un univers de
science-fiction pourquoi il y a eu une
omerta sur la présence de de de
scientifique allemand sur le territoire
français je dirais que ça a été la la
même chose aux États-Unis avec Van Brown
il est arrivé aux États-Unis c'était
sous le plus grand secret pendant 4 5
ans personne n'était au courant de rien
surtout pas la presse et après l'affaire
a un peu
explosé avec le fait que Van Brand a été
du parti
nazi les recherches conduites en
Normandie par les anciens collaborateurs
de Werner von Brown sont restés entourés
jusqu'au bout d'un épais
mystère eux-mêmes conservent une
discrétion totale sur les raisons de
leur
présence
on savait qu'il travaillait sur des des
moteurs de fusée sur des fusées mais
Alex les pères ne parlaient de rien
souvent les épouses ne savaient pas ce
que faisait leur mari tellement cé
secret ils ont été formés comme ça et
tous les papiers qui circulai par
exemple dans l'usine et cetera sont été
tamponnés secret ét numéroté et cetera
il y avait aussi un petit côté cocorico
qui était de pas de pas trop révéler que
c'était grâce grâce aux Allemands et au
cerveau allemand que on avait fabriqué
les premières fusées
Véronique qui qui fusé sonde qui qui
volait à magir et autres donc la fierté
nationale
voulait était plutôt de montrer que
c'était grâce aux ingénieurs
français ceci c'est Véronique la
fusée
les ingénieurs allemands de Vernon se
voient confier le secteur propulsion des
fusées le général de Gaulle a demandé à
ce qu'on développe par exemple une fusée
antiavion la parca qui a été développé
au LRBA pour descendre les bombardiers
russes qui sont chargés de bombes
atomiqu ça bien sûr en tant que
enfance on sait que c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait nouveau et quelque chose
qui va faire changer le monde mais ces
premiers missiles sol R ou mer r impulsé
par des équipes allemandes rencontrent
des problèmes de
guidage le développement de plusieurs
fusées est
abandonné les ingénieurs allemands de
Normandie se concentrent dans les années
60 sur la conception de moteur de
lancement toujours plus puissant ces
réalisations très spectaculaires vont de
Véronique dont il a déjà été tiré plus
de 70 exemplaire au premier étage
émeraude du lance satellite
diamant et à Cora 2è étage du lanceur
européen
eldosestes deux derniers engins réalis
les recrues allemandes mettent au point
un moteur fusé qui équipera les premiers
étages de tous les lances satellites
jusqu'en 2003 jusqu'au dernier vol de la
fusée arien
4 et ça a été comme ça que que la France
a pu fabriquer des fusées et devenir un
peu leader européen
d'Arian mission accomplie on estime que
le travail des scientifiques allemands a
fait gagner à la France 15 précieuses
années de recherches et
d'études ils sont pour la plupart
repartis l'Allemagne partir des années
60 a été en mesure de leur proposer des
postes
équivalents seul quelques familles sont
restées en France sans attirer
[Musique]
l'attention moi ça ça ne m'a jamais
troublé que qu'on soit resté un peu dans
l'ombre beaucoup ou beaucoup dans
l'ombre ça nous a pas non je sais et mon
père non
plus aucune d'aucune façon ça l'a
troublé
entouré par le secret défense
l'existence de ces colonies allemandes
sur le sol français n'a jamais été porté
à la connaissance du grand
[Musique]
public